[Musik]
hallo herzlichen karussell it well heute
gleich drei sätze in eine untiefe
rezepte überraschungs form roth salat
endlich mal was gesundes sich kein salat
demokrat auch wenn ich für dich echt
aussieht aber das ist ein frühstücks
ideen und zwar kennt ihr das vielleicht
dass ihr morgen immer ziemlich gestresst
zeit kommt bei uns auch als vor allem
wenn wir wegmüssen oder mora zu arbeiten
muss man vergisst gerne mal auch das
frühstück und familie und ich sitzen
dann am frühstückstisch ganz alleine und
oftmals vergibt sogar was mitzunehmen
weil und sagt ich habe gar keine zeit
mehr gehabt vor lauter windelwechseln
die wäsche waschen müll rausbringen
machte noch morgens alle falschparker
und zeigen zeichen seitens auch meist
die zeit im austeilen männer zwischen
vier und sechs bin ich unterwegs ist
will man ist demokratischer zeigen chlor
ist alles klappt genau so viele wie
murat gibt's dann die idee einfach das
frühstück am abend vorher zuzubereiten
das heißt overnight im kühlschrank zu
lagern problems mit den sockeln freitag
hat man ein richtiges problem aber dann
braucht man keine rezepte sondern eine
hilfe einer ebenfalls hat nur die
brocken
[Gelächter]
jedenfalls habe ich hier drei
haferflocken widersetze und die werden
wirklich abends zubereitet kommen in den
kühlschrank
und dann könnt ihr am nächsten tag
einfach nicht glasverpackungen und mit
ins büro nehmen zur arbeit oder zur
schule
was ist richtig toll findet denn über
nacht können die haben uns noch einmal
zu matschig und dann könnt ihr wirklich
alles noch miteinander verglichen das
erste rezept 100 gramm kernigen
haferflocken 100 mini familie von speed
von joghurt 1,5 prozent fettanteil etwas
sonne legt eine halbe bier ein paar
himberg und einen esslöffel mandeln gibt
es ein reiches geröstet und es sind auch
gehobelte mandeln aber ihr könnt da zum
beispiel auch dokus verwenden und die
auch vorher in der pfanne ohne fett
fressen
es geht jetzt alles super einfach ich
hier mein glas bekommen jetzt die
haferflocken rein
[Musik]
er kommt auf die menschen über
hier erst mal kurz stehen lassen und
kümmere mich jetzt um die pläne für
papier und entfernen
[Musik]
und jetzt findet die birne entwickeln
oder in scheiben schneiden
ich mach dich entscheiden und war habe
ich ein tolles gerät das ist auch eine
richtig tolle alternative für alle die
keltischen maschine haben und einfach
eine alternative suchen wie man trotzdem
schnell gemüse und oft klein bekommt und
da gibt's auch ein auflauf extra kapitel
zu wenig maschine nur dass hier eben
selber den betten quote und christiane
schreibe mir zusammen im schreiben
schneiden
[Musik]
letztere ist hier den joghurt mit
wohnsitz in vanille
die könnt ihr natürlich weglassen aber
ich find's super lecker hier ein
geschlecht ist das heißt zuerst die
firmen
[Musik]
danke jungs
die himbeeren und da könnt ihr gerne
auch andere software anderen früchte
nehmen und ganz oben drauf noch die man
durch und bekommt vier der deckel drauf
und dann stelle ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank und las ich dann wie gesagt
über nacht stehen jetzt zeige ich euch
noch ein fall für das weitere zeit
brauchen keine glocken eine banane
das sind fast einer halben zitrone das
format noch von etwa 200 konzerten und
einem ausblick für dieses rezept rauch
sieht einen baustopp oder einfach mit
gabel sind süchtig machen ist das heißt
ich nehme banane bedarf auch gern ist er
reich sein das heißt sie darf auch
braune flecken auf das schale haben denn
da ist nämlich umso süßer banane kommt
darüber gingen
der abruf von der zitronenschale sah es
noch ganz wichtig dass es eine
unbehandelte zitrone ist dann kommt auch
noch der saft einer halben zitrone
[Applaus]
[Musik]
trainiert werden die zutaten püriert
nämlich wieder mein schönes klar da
kommen die haarlocken rein und werden
dann mit der bananen mensch über gucken
pinkwart führe ich jetzt mit etwa von
elektra kommt dann auch darüber
informiert könnt ihr auch den quark
schon mit der meldung mit dem banalen
verrühren
aber ich find auch ganz schön wenn man
so 230 grad vor allem flick super aus
und da zählt natürlich auch also brauch
ist damit das sieht auch die optik und
ich finde auch ganz schön 23
verschiedenen konsistenzen fahren
wichtig ist nur dass die bananen
menschen mit den flocken gefunden erst
damit sie auch über nacht einweichen
kann
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich noch kirschen
entscheiden und auch darüber geben
[Musik]
mit einer profitiert mit 39 geparkt
haben
da kommen kokosflocken betreiben und
dann kann auch verschließen und auch zu
stellen w40 1
und jetzt geht's dir sass nur dran
für ein drittes rezept braucht 50 gramm
kernigen haferflocken 100 millimetern
mädels 25 minute auch auf 100 gramm
magerquark ein fertig und einem kabuler
jetzt nehme ich das zur ersten abend
locken sie kommen über ende gefehlt -
drüber und ich habe es hier ganz normale
vollmilch erkennt aber auch zum beispiel
hameln folie mit mandelmilch kuchen ist
oder was auch immer noch ihr könnt die
rezepte aufzunehmen und weg ist ganz
einfach nicht gestalten mit schwarzen
elster seite und quark mit orangensaft
verrühren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leider stellen und sich zu nehmen und
einfach in würfel oder entfalten
[Musik]
und quark gebe ich jetzt hier über die
haferflocken
hier könnt ihr zum beispiel auch ein
bisschen auch auf die schadenabwicklung
falls ja auch noch frischer orange
genommen hatte
[Applaus]
da kommen stücke mit sein
[Musik]
und jetzt optische highlight die
maracuja da gibt auch verschiedene die
hier sitzen tief im keller ich kenne sie
so dass wir auf unsere dunkle fast
schwarze frau zu schnell und die muss
aus runkel seiten sind sehr heiß und
richtig
[Musik]
jetzt am besten mit einem lasso aber
sehr lecker und gesund
[Musik]
und auch dieses frühstück kommt jetzt in
den kühlschrank
wir haben jetzt zwar nicht über nacht im
kühlschrank aber ich muss sagen muss
dass trotzdem probieren macht natürlich
ganz viel studiert zwei sätzen paar
schichten haben dass ihr sie einfach vor
dem verzehren sich um durchmischt oder
einfach von oben nach unten das machen
würdest du gerne probieren erheben mehr
und maracuja was mit roland und so muss
natürlich wissen kein zuckerzusatz nur
sein heimatdorf kein pokern oder vanilla
alles gesund ja das ist meine
arbeitskollegen nicht glauben wo ich
mich schon ein bisschen autocar einfach
wirklich letzte harte worte nein zu sein
kann ich gespannt
aber es ist ein klub aus schmeckt
richtig durch ich bin auch diese
kombination maracuja mit joghurt richtig
denn ja ok und vor allem können wir die
planung auch wirklich so machen
atom-moratorium beispiel auch ein
größeres glas bekommen wenn er sagt das
reicht nicht
ich kann mir auch ein bisschen weniger
was tun also da können wir einfach schon
zu sehen es besteht überhaupt studenten
und paypal vorgeworfen er weist vorbei
ist auch genau die klever bin ich vor
allem richtig cool denn vergeht noch so
ein einsatz
das heißt wenn erst zum beispiel kein
frühstück mehr menschen sondern
mittagessen oder im salat
da kann aber auch salat einschließen und
jedes fressen rein machen und dann
einfach so mit reinhängen und feldsalat
drin
fans der salat nicht aber egal
die rezepte nachlesen wolf angeht
auffällig - blog.de vielleicht noch ein
paar rezept ideen wie man über nacht im
kühlschrank stehen lassen kann und
morgens wirklich keinen stress mehr hat
und die zeit für andere dinge mussten
erstens das verärgert aber es muss also
viel spaß beim nachmachen und willst du
nicht normal so könnte man sagen wir
euch die kosten im jahr wirklich super
gefahren
ich kenn ich hab mal auch in der nacht
oder schon mehrere nächte
das auto ist vergessen und ich hab's
aber ich hab's aber später zu den
mehrfarbiges gewählt
und ich glaube ganz akkurat das klingt
der regen was im auto deshalb gilt
jedoch nichts ein will jedoch nichts ein
und irgendwann beim auto putzen harder
und 50 cent und geht von new york und
dem wirklich also im sommer passiert ist
von alleine weg gelaufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]